a beaucoup de conséquences
sur de futures applications concrètes en architecture.
Par exemple, vous voyez ici une maison
conçue pour un promoteur en Chine,
qui est en fait une boîte en verre de quatre étages.
Elle est toute en verre, parce qu'on veut toujours une vue dégagée,
mais elle est gainée de cette couche de bimétal thermique,
c'est un écran qui en fait le tour, et cette couche peut réellement s'ouvrir et se fermer
en fonction du déplacement du soleil sur la surface.
En plus de ça, elle peut aussi cacher certains endroits aux regards
de façon à les distinguer des parties publiques,
selon le moment de la journée.
Ce que ça implique au fond, c'est que maintenant, dans les maisons,
nous n'avons plus besoin de rideaux, de volets, ni de persiennes,
parce que nous pouvons recouvrir les immeubles avec ça,
et contrôler la quantité d'air conditionné nécessaire.
J'envisage aussi d'essayer de développer des éléments de construction pour le marché.
Vous voyez ici une fenêtre classique,
à double vitrage, et à l'intérieur,
entre ces deux panneaux de verre, ce double vitrage,
j'essaie d'obtenir
un système de forme en bilame thermique,
de façon à ce que, lorsque le soleil frappe la couche externe,
et réchauffe l'espace intérieur, le bilame thermique commence à se recourber,
et ce qui se passe alors,
c'est qu'il va commencer à arrêter les rayons du soleil
dans certaines parties de l'immeuble,
voire entièrement, si nécessaire.
Vous pouvez donc imaginer, rien qu'avec cette application,
que dans un immeuble de grande hauteur, où le système de vitrages
va d'étage en étage jusqu'à 30 ou 40 étages, toute la surface
pourrait se comporter différemment, à divers moments de la journée,
en fonction de la façon dont le soleil la parcourt et la frappe.
Voici des projets ultérieurs, sur lesquels je travaille en ce moment même,
qui sont à l'étude, où vous pouvez voir
en bas à droite, en rouge, de plus petites pièces de métal thermique
que l'on essaie vraiment de faire bouger
comme des cils.
Ce dernier projet concerne également des éléments de construction.
L'inspiration - vous avez dû le remarquer,
l'un de mes domaines d'inspiration est la biologie - me vient de la sauterelle.
Les sauterelles ont un système respiratoire différent.
Elles respirent par des trous sur le côté, appelés spiracles,
elles aspirent l'air, qui traverse leur corps, pour les refroidir.
Alors dans ce projet, j'essaie d'étudier comment nous pourrions
envisager ça également en architecture, comment nous pourrions amener de l'air
au travers de trous pratiqués sur les côtés des immeubles.
Voici quelques études préliminaires de blocs,
qui sont en fait entièrement percés de trous,
là c'est avant que le bilame thermique soit installé,
et là c'est après l'installation du bilame. Désolée, c'est un peu dur à voir,
mais à la surface, on peut voir ces flèches rouges.
A gauche, quand c'est froid, le bilame thermique est plat,
et va donc empêcher l'air de passer au travers du bloc,
et à droite, le bilame thermique se courbe
et permet à l'air de passer. Ce sont donc deux éléments différents
sur lesquels je travaille, et là encore,
il s'agit de tout autre chose, parce qu'on peut imaginer
que l'air puisse entrer à travers des murs
au lieu d'ouvrir les fenêtres.
Je veux vous laisser sur une dernière impression à propos de ce projet,
ou de ce type de travail, et l'utilisation de matériaux intelligents.
Quand vous serez fatigués d'ouvrir et de fermer ces volets,
jour après jour, quand vous serez en vacances,
et qu'il n'y aura personne le week-end pour allumer et éteindre les appareils,
ou quand il y aura une coupure de courant, et que vous ne pourrez plus compter
sur l'électricité, ces bilames thermiques fonctionneront encore,
inlassablement, efficacement, et pour toujours.
Merci. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)